The jogan Experience so you are how many
months out since your
injury almost five yeah my wife was just
here and we were talking about how we
went to see your game we set it up we're
going to go see Aaron play he's going to
be playing the Cowboys in Dallas let's
go we got all pumped up and and four
plays later yeah yeah how is it now it
feels good it feels good I can do
everything except uh Sprint at a top
speed so um the cool thing is I the I
really attacked the reab the first few
months and kind of wanted to go as hard
as I could for two months to see where I
was at and also see where the team was
at cuz my goal was to come back um
nobody has come back uh really quick
from that injury most of the time when
it happens especially during season
there's no need uh to push a rehab
because it happened the first week of
the season I
said you know let's push this as hard as
I can and see if I can come back in
December at some point so I kind of my
mind had circled Christmas Eve which
would have been 14 weeks post uh surgery
and yeah I worked really really hard I
had a great surgeon uh who did uh you
know a newer process where they kind of
uh attach uh anchor the uh uh the
sutures through the tendon back into
your heel so it allows you to get on
your feet quicker um I did a lot of you
know uh other things to U speed up the
reab iated hyper barck chamber uh work
with the Bri Brigham at ways to well you
know I know you're very good friends
with and saw him in the podcast here and
he's amazing um he did some stem cells
did uh uh you know full-time rehab uh up
to eight hours a day with u you know an
incredible spot in LA and also at home
doing extra stuff uh my diet was Rock
Solid um a lot of bone broth um to
increase the collagen levels to increase
healing and so I felt you know I felt
really really good I made it back on the
practice field um at 11 weeks
weeks um the way the NFL works with the
IR you can uh have a 3-we window before
they got to make a decision so they
designate you to return you have three
weeks before you get activated so I was
hoping we'd win those three games I
could come back now I couldn't Sprint
and still can't at top speed but I felt
like there's been times in my career
where I played in a small circle it
could have been able to be effective U
that didn't happen uh and so they uh
didn't they activate me to the roster I
just got to practice um but I didn't get
to play but uh I feel good you know um
it it was I had a lot of things working
against me my age being the biggest one
but uh I learned a lot about a lot more
about health which I'm sure people would
love to hear about yeah um I mean if you
follow like a wayte to well protocol you
can pretty radically speed up recovery
for injuries you know um and what's
interesting is that there's stuff that
you can do that you didn't do because
it's not allowed which is you know very
admirable on your part but I would I
would have [__] done it I I would
have done everything like let's go I
would have gone the full Conor McGregor
route but um when you do how do they
determine whether or not you are fully
here do they do an MRI and check the
tissue and yeah we were doing the
ultrasounds actually for a while just to
see what type of blood flow we were
getting to the area um we didn't
actually do another MRI if I had been uh
activated with the intent to play I
think just for safety for everybody we
probably would have done another MRI
just to see the Integrity structural
Integrity of the tendon um but really it
was about how I felt you know and I was
able to to do all the quarterback stuff
um move in the pocket um throw uh step
into my foot I could actually you know
jog to slightly faster than a jog to
move and throw um all things I kind of
showed in practice the last few weeks
this what happens over that if you speed
it up a little do you feel pain do you
feel I I don't have the explosion I
don't have the ability to kind of um get
up on my toe the the biggest uh hurdle
was just single leg calf strength like
being able to from a standing position
shift my weight onto the single leg and
do a heel race um that to that's how you
know you're ready to run because you run
on your athletes play on their toes you
know so I need to be able to to do that
now I could get around that by subtle
movements in the pocket but there was
multiple times throughout my career had
lower leg injuries in 14 and 18
especially where I was able to play in a
small circle in 14 I ripped my calf up
pretty bad and was able to kind of play
in the shotgun and the pistol um for a
stretch of time and be effective in 18 I
banged my knee up on the uh second Drive
of the game uh you tore my MCL had a um
uh you know fracture on the lateral side
and was able to play uh for a while uh
in mostly in the shotgun until that
healed up but so I knew I could do it I
wanted to show I could play Under Center
which I did uh in practice but um you
know we just were out of it so so I
didn't come back well it seems like it's
the smartest move at your age to make
sure it's 100% like like I've seen a lot
of athletes come back particularly from
ACL injuries with Fighters they come
back too soon and Pops
again yeah I I I totally agree with that
on on many levels but then there's the
competitor report where I see that uh
that window closing and um there's not
many guys who've been who've played as
long as I have there's a few obviously
Tom did it for a long time but you know
there's kind of an age where father time
is is winning and I know that you know
I'm I'm on the last couple holes of my
career so I didn't want to miss an
entire season are you 36 now I'm 40 40
thank you though you look